Oh,
I was about 18 when I first came to
London.
I was the first trip I took to Europe.
I saved up money for a whole year to
travel through Europe for a few months
with some friends of mine was the age of
London.
That really struck me because I'd come
in from western Canada and hadn't
traveled much at that point and of
course western Canada.
The town I grew up in was only
established in the 19 thirties.
Really no one to walk into pubs that had
been around for five or 600 years was
something unheard of in Canada.
The magnificence of the architecture and
the fact that things were built to last.
The parliament buildings are remarkable
and the castles and the depth of history
and the stability of the country,
all of that and the freedom.
It's an amazing achievement as far as
I'm concerned.
One of the things that we learned in the
west and one of the things that's part
of the great English journalistic
tradition is that journalists and
predicted or have the freedom to say
what they want and what they want and
that keeps everyone including the
journalists honest and on track,
and we sacrifice that,
especially at the feet of the idea that
no one is to be oppressed by anything
anyone else says.
We sacrifice that at our complete peril.
It's the.
It's the cardinal,
right?
Because when people speak freely,
they're able to think and people orient
themselves in the world by thinking and
they re update the state by thinking and
they conquer unknown lands by thinking
and if you put restrictions on their
ability to speak freely,
then you put restrictions on their
ability to think and all of those other
processes grind to a halt and then
everyone suffers for it.
Interesting.
Well,
I started reading George Orwell when I
was a kid about 13 or 14.
Then my read 1984 and animal farm of
course,
because that's the books that everyone
starts with,
and then later in my life,
no,
I became aware of how prescient George
Orwell was with regards to the dangerous
of totalitarianism.
He was one of the first intellectuals in
the west to sound the alarm about what
was going on,
especially in the Soviet Union or wells.
Definitely one of my intellectual heroes
from the 20th century.
He's been a hero of mine consistently.
Britain holds a special place in the
hearts of Canadians and for good reason.
You know,
you guys got so many things right.
English common law tradition and the
parliamentary tradition and no,
it's been a great gift to everywhere in
the world as far as I'm concerned.